why is defecation on his face have you
always does but yeah all right Emre lies
whoo hey everybody I'm Deadpool all
right everybody welcome i'm betty from
comic story in that cell from the Little
House comics we're gonna drop the TV
section we've made that official
announcement now even though he hasn't
decided it and that Wow
guess what guys he's not dead like we
all thought the further for the record
he was not just an animatronic puppet
that I was doing the boys for he's a
real person still so as usual this week
we've got the World's End issue 5 were
real energy fighting grunt we've got
Rocket Raccoon guess what there was
another red Cooper isn't the legendary
star-lord I stopped reading that to eat
years ago why am I still getting it
we've got injustice into the green don't
know what's going on with that one we
got green arrow and they've just now
finally brought in Felicity Smoak
I told you this browser never know
what's going on abyss but if somebody's
parachuting hi Grayson earth to he's
doing some weird [ __ ]
we've got where's my book sweet happy
turtle with Bane we've got the edge of
the spider versus you one we've got axis
issue for hopefully it's good we don't
disturb for too long because you lose
your mind
the second issue of girly Lobo and we've
got spider-ham
spider-ham spider-ham does but everybody
could pick now I've messed up my song
the more I listen to like when you do
your intros and you talk about DC Comics
the more I'm glad I don't read that [ __ ]
well this one you want to go ahead and
drag all my DC Comics spider him through
the spectacular spider Han hello
universe words like the Muppets but
there but the kicker is is that they've
made him like a primary character of the
spider first that they reckoned him so
now he's like he's like cracking wise
and he's like a douche it's why do I
have a weird feeling that next season on
the Disney XD we're gonna get a
spider-ham TV show we owe a whole show
man I don't know you know like he's been
in the show though like spectacular
spider-man it spider-ham has
that was spectacular spider-man no not
the new ultimate spider-man no no I mean
like the new Disney XD spider-man yeah
already acts like a childish little
cartoon from the anime that's gonna be
he's gonna get easy to be in it or get a
show he's in ready
spider-ham has already appeared on
ultimate spider-man it's see somebody
like posted a comment in one of my
videos I think it was like like the run
down for spider-man for like Civil War
and they were like will you do a video
explaining spider-verse and I was like
nope I've been getting those comments -
will you do spider person I'm like yes I
will when it ends
it's a good series going on for four
months and it just started there was
confused as I am I don't know I don't
know man it just started like trust me
though we will do a back issues once the
last issue it happened I'm like boom
we're gonna do it because I I'm already
not interested I'm already hating it um
I'll take this time to say that this
right here all of you guys can see that
this is yes it is this is nature's
paintbrush and this is the best the
freakin best smelling candle
Thank You candle oh yeah thank you like
you can't find them anymore so I had to
order it off eBay today's topics are
going to be the 2015 Secret Wars event
event went up on all of our channels by
the way coolest thing ever to get an
email from Marvel that is very generic
and says you can put this on your
channel tomorrow that's like here's
something for you as opposed to we're
taking this away from you I like your
argument and we're gonna talk about that
today we're gonna talk about big hero 6
and why is why is it even called big
hero 6 um and we're gonna discuss access
and why I hate it and why Rob loves it
and I don't think sounds even reading it
no I hate it but I also want to take
this moment to give a PSA for everyone
who likes to leave shitty comments down
below for for various hosts like such as
myself or when they were commenting a
date or those people that really hate
Italian people named Sal why are you
watching our show we're here every week
show week I'm here these are the host
people like that's it every week I'm
gonna drink too much caffeine and
interrupt people when they're talking
then every week Rob's gonna sit here and
go I would like to let you guys know
those of you guys that didn't get a
chance to meet us at Comic Con Vinny's
just as much of an [ __ ] in real life
as he is on the podcast okay you guys
know I'm gonna back up what Rob said but
I'm not gonna say what the context was
but after after the first day ended Rob
came to my hotel room and he walked in
he goes Benny wouldn't need to talk stop
being an [ __ ] we don't move this is
no different I'm an ass you know I'm an
[ __ ] I told you I was an [ __ ]
so so what point did you expect me to
not be an [ __ ] when we met he goes
well that's a good point
I mean it's it wasn't like like a
malicious like you know like I'm just
walking up and I'm like being mean to
people and like telling women that like
they're terrible or something like that
it was just like it just being okay I
mean whatever should be aware that Rob
didn't bring his vapes oh I was a little
touchy for another funny story you guys
all think Rob is nice and common cool
we've had to see Rob six hours of no
vapes I think it one point he snapped
and Sal for the ride or something and at
one point he was about to like beat a
bunch of people at the convention cuz
they're getting in his way it was
hilarious I was prepared like murder
people like I was for sure that I was
probably gonna stab somebody to death of
New York Comicon but it means that were
like go ahead and do what you got to do
man yeah some more stuff yeah totally
left me hanging you guys are just like
well we're gonna be over here and then
like I look over and you guys are gone
I'm buying it i 100% believe that you
guys were watching me and then as soon
as I turn around you guys just ran off
oh I may have done that when you me and
Dave were going down one of the aisles
and you stopped at an artist and I'm
like now's my chance
okay that place was so it was total
pandemonium all right like whoa I'll say
this and then we got to get back on
topic but but it was it was so
pandemonium like like me and Tiffany and
Danielle and Sal and Dave and Benny like
we were all together I'm like okay where
we gonna go look at first they were like
well let's go look at how many books and
stuff like that so we're like okay we're
in that place for two minutes and
everybody's out on their own so
everything okay so here's how me of
Robert quick before we go into the
actual proper topic of the day so I'm
walking along as Rob and Rob stops to
look at a painting and he goes I want to
buy the painting and I'm like I think
they sell prints and Rob goes but I
really want to buy the painting that's
where Rob left me so I said I can go
into the next booth thinking Rob was
with me
and I turn around and apparently Rob was
buying the entire wall of paintings I
know he was right with us no I just I
just like okay I'm on my own I got a
phone they can call me yeah I was like
well I tried like I well no I sent you a
text and then I was thinking like man
should I call him cuz it's like noisy as
hell in here
and then I called Benny Benny answered
his phone he's like you really think
you're gonna be able to hear me like
well maybe really depleted cell phone
battery life as well oh my god for some
reason there was just no way to do
anything yeah it was crazy okay so
anyway wants to get on track so so
zipper wars 2015 alright so all these
events seem to be like revolve around
secret Wars now you know what Rob I'm
just gonna say right now what we just
saw these people know I mean this is an
interruption I know it is but guys we
know as much as you they sent that video
like don't worry guys they were like
here's here's the video put it on your
channel we were like okay in saligan
asked him what is this and he goes don't
worry about it so yeah people like send
me messages like what's really supposed
to be happening I'm like alright like
Marvel didn't tell us and then make a
sign like non-disclosure agreement no we
just don't know alright let's let's give
some context Marvel as anybody's
Drake wants to join us midway through a
foot okay oh that's fun oh it's been
releasing like big one-page teasers
about like with no context oh yeah like
super easy house them Age of Apocalypse
old man Logan
spider-man Mary Jane and their kid renew
your vows a ton of them there's a lot of
different and they're all like the
events that you remember but a little
askew I would say like here's here's the
question because one thing to keep in
mind is I think Mar will set the stage
with this was the age of Ultron because
as much as people didn't like it like I
know Sal it's just like age of Ultron
was good until like issue number six and
then it just got dumb after that well
most series comic books don't know how
to end yeah awesome if they're written
by Dennis oh crap dude this can end
series well great well what about
Hickman Hickman just ends a series by
starting a new series by moving a DC I
for me I love Hickman stories like
Hickman writes some of the coolest stuff
like the New Avengers all I kind of
stuff with Hickman was really really
good but then all the sudden it's just
like here's some stuff happening and
we're done onto the new thing but great
well I think that they they started all
this with Wolverine and the whole
screwing up the timeline yes of an age
of Ultron so I think what happened is
the ripple effect that took place where
Galactus got sent to the ultimate
universe channel I kind of get stuff
where Angela shows up in the main
earth-616 universe I think that's going
to be a ripple effect that's going to
affect like the past things that took
place previously okay because well
remember like an age of Ultron like in
the defenders you have Peter quill who
was part of the defenders yes yeah and
so Marvel's established the fact that in
alternate timelines things happen
entirely different like like the when
Peter quill first showed up in Marvel
Comics he first showed up in guardians
of the galaxy as well before that but as
far as like you know his popularity yeah
the guardians of the galaxy but instead
they're saying the first superhero team
part of with the defenders yeah and so I
think that's what they're gonna do here
with this whole thing is they're going
to use seeker wars to introduce all
these other universes that we didn't
know about or the universes that we did
know about and say that things had more
or less played out differently due to
the actions of Wolverine screwing up
time I don't know I I think that they're
stealing the idea of DC they're doing an
imminent crisis now what DC does is
every time you have a what-if or an else
world it's a whole new universe and they
establish that this universe exists and
it keeps moving no matter what you think
it's always still going on and so
whenever we have a crisis at DC all of
these universes normally collide and
ended up fighting Final Crisis Superman
went to all the worlds and got all the
Superman's yeah it's the first city he's
going that they're going through all the
worlds right now
Infinite Crisis they shattered them all
tried to merge him up and I have a
feeling that's what Marvel is gonna do
they're gonna be like hey age of Ultron
that still happened that was over here
secret Wars that still happened it was
over here and that and then the new
secret war is this universe is fighting
instead of the old one and that's that's
the war rule I think what they're doing
is they're warping at all of these
universes into the one central point and
I think it's gonna come right out of the
incursian storyline I'm actually coming
out of the video for the incursion
storyline next week but who could risk
wish me luck guys it's the only story
I'm doing next week because it's
probably gonna take me all week to sort
out it's it's nuts man it's it's crazy
but like like me and Sal were talking
earlier and like the Age of Apocalypse
universe didn't end they had the ten
year anniversary for Age of Apocalypse
and they like picked up where the story
left off after the nuclear bombardment
you know and stuff on wove around rogue
and Magneto and when they picked up
after year two turned out like Jean Grey
had saved everybody and apparently she
had the powers of the Phoenix and like
all this stuff was going on like you
still had this ongoing universe that was
still taking place and that's why I say
I think that what Marvel is doing here
is you know these are alternate
realities or these are points in time
that were adjusted something else
happened because of the actions of
Wolverine I mean instead of having like
all these different superheroes against
Thanos you had like Peter quill I guess
who now wields the Infinity dollars and
the
like that I don't know what they're
gonna was I mean in the end it's all
just speculation we don't know until
next year right well the big speculation
is that supposedly Marva was having a
crisis and it looks like they are that
the question is gonna be is at the end
of this event when DC does this David
root everything that's like you see a
crisis you know things are not gonna go
back to the status quo at the end of the
whole thing there's gonna take five more
years to get another crisis to fix it
that's not everyone thinks happening
with the new 52 right now we're gonna
get a crisis to fix the new 52 but
everyone's been speculating at marbles
kind of been hinting at this with
infinity in the age of Ultron and all
these other events that are been
happening and it looks like that's the
direction we're gonna go and it looks
like the secret war is gonna resolve now
my question is are we just gonna move
forward at six one six or are we now
gonna have a new merged universe this
may be a way for them to shut down the
alternate universe finally oh yeah one
of the promos is the ultimate universe
is gonna die yeah I said what's the
problem the valta uterus is a problem
cuz the only thing anyone ever likes it
out is Miles Morales and it just feels
like they keep trying to shoehorn other
concepts in with the ultimate and no one
ever likes them the Ultimate Universe
was never supposed to be its own
universe it was supposed to be just a
separate publishing label and like the
fact they started treating it like a
universe like it's part of the
multiverse of Marvel was a mistake
because then it allowed all the Marvel
cosmic [ __ ] to infect it and so as a
result like the ultimate universe the
other problem there's two problems with
ultimate universe number one is that
number one is like treating it like it's
the 6-1-6 universe which is not it
shouldn't be it's supposed to be like if
the you ultimately if the Marvel
Universe was real and started in 2001
that's supposed to look like number two
they let Jeff lobe get anywhere near it
because everything that Jeff Allah wrote
for it is effing terrible like really
really bit and undisputedly bad and it
just root like the x-men are destroyed
because of Jeff lobe the whole Avengers
was destroyed because Jeff lobe
Quicksilver and Scarlet Witch are like
trying to in breed and stuff it's just
like everything about it was just a
disaster
the infamous relationship between Scott
Irwin quick the only thing that was good
about it was what Bendis
was doing with it when he invented it
and like ultimately I think the ultimate
universe will die with the first book I
think like that's my first things I do
for me as long as they saved when Aunt
May and Miles Morales I'm good well
they're setting that up
I don't cuz no you actually you guys
aren't reading I'm the other one the
result New Mexico all because they won't
read all me Waxman since like issue
number 1700 it was yeah there was a
whole segment in the middle there where
I just went to crap and they were just
stretching it out but what happened now
is the x-men they finally decided to
start being the x-men and so the first
thing they did as a group of their own
device was go to a mutant who had the
ability to warp between universes the
first thing she did was warp them to the
Ultimate Universe so the only waxman are
there where they're now teaming up with
Miles Morales and they're looking for a
way to get home so and if you go to
Miles Morales book he's currently
fighting against Peter Parker's back you
know how they kill Peter Parker though
the universe they don't know if it's a
clone or the official yet but he's back
now in the Ultimate Universe so with
this setting up and this is my
prediction guys Miles Morales is gonna
join the all-new x-men going back to the
6-1-6 leaving Peter Parker as the
spider-man of the Ultimate Universe and
then they're gonna kill the Ultimate
Universe oh my god you know what would
happen I know what would happen if
Marvel did that if like this whole
summer 2015 event comes to an end and
Peter Parker's not spider-man in the
main earth-616 universe anymore
have a both of saying like just and what
they're gonna do is put this new Peter
Parker back as the spider mite of the
Ultimate Universe that way we can still
have the epic spider-man dies moment you
know looks like we're doing that it
looks like they might be setting
something similar to that up because of
spider-verse because they're kind of
like the first like three pages of the
new Spider verse book was saying like
there are way too many spider related
characters in the 6-1-6 universe we have
Peter Parker we got Miguel O'Hara
we've got Jessica drew we've got Iranian
we have that's it actually no in the
snow silk soaks now they're silicon cane
so we have six spider characters running
around phantom Dean
spider characters that I did the spider
character yeah but he's not in it
and now cartage has his own book if you
guys see that yeah yeah so we got a 1 or
something like that you know you know
what I think they're trying to do though
is what they're trying not the end of
accent he has his own book now literally
yeah I'm saying like at the end of H is
they have a list of titles that were
getting number ones yeah oh yeah I think
I think they listed like carnage as
getting and then they were like an
update to Mac ok let me tell you
something the the only really cool thing
that I even enjoyed about magneto solo
comic so far is like during axis it
shows him like killing off Red Skull
when they said like don't kill him yeah
you do
like really bad stuffs gonna happen and
he was like no nah making these mutant
prisoners like we're just gonna kill him
and so he kills them and then he comes
as a show that was like red onslaught ya
know I think it's been tight I really
like that manga I mean maybe I should go
back and reread it man but I read I read
issues there were issues number one and
two and then I took a break from it and
then I got caught back up on the other
roads or whatever it is that they called
it basically like what passes for the
road to access you know what I think
that's what they're calling it and did
just to get caught up on why he was part
of actions in the first place which one
of the coolest points in action so far
and we'll get back to the event here an
aside one of the coolest points and axes
was issue number two or number three I
can for which one but it's like when Red
Skull has like more or less taken out
everybody and then like magneto bails
out and they're like where are you going
and then he comes back and he's got like
Deadpool with him and like Deadpool
dragging Tony Stark the grill
and the whole time he's like can I be an
adventure now where are you bringing me
Deadpool even if you are saving my life
I will never even give you a temporary
Avengers card anything no where are you
bringing me and it feels like I thought
you just needed some juice I was gonna
charge you he comes back and he's like
that was such a great moment it was such
a great like a fun team anyway so back
to the work week with the Deadpool thing
does he have funny cuz if you're reading
the Deadpool book he has his own
adventure going on with his daughter at
the time so everyone
literally they're running has Deadpool
like he's he's busy doing his own thing
in the city and they're all running past
him like Deadpool we gotta go fight
Rhett onslaught you gotta compress risk
crazy stuff that he's in the x-men house
and they're doing this that like like um
Evan shows up the the kid apocalypse
we're all time Ryan goes you got this
okay and so that's why the first comedy
he makes when he shows up in Access 3 is
hey guys I'm miss Thea the superhero
tree but don't worry I hitched a ride
with the villains okay see I've been
keeping up with Deadpool solo series but
I need to like I need to just for the
sake of all my fans out there that love
Deadpool which I don't understand why
but all them to love Deadpool they want
me to like you know keep tabs on
Deadpool I'll have to but I don't know I
mean if what you say is true or Binnie
like you're talking about like a crisis
where they're basically gonna like reset
everything they're gonna say okay fine
we've got all these characters and we're
gonna obliterate like a whole bunch of
them remove a whole bunch of them we're
gonna have like a few left well that's
what I think they're doing that's that's
honestly and I might be crazy about this
I think that's what spider-verse is out
of all of the multi-universe is the most
popular characters in these multiple
universes is the spider-man characters
yeah so what I think spider-verse is is
a way to resit like I think they're
gonna the incursions are gonna end with
killing off the multiverse stuff they're
gonna have their own crisis moment it's
got all gonna end two years down the
road we're gonna find out it's all still
around but no one knew about it and the
most popular Spider characters I think
are gonna get pulled into the six months
X that's why 2099 showed up there and I
think that's that the gwen stacy is
gonna show up there she's good she's not
gonna get to go home I think Miles
Morales is gonna get pulled in we're
gonna have a crap ton of spider-man in
here and it's gonna become its own like
own thing now where we have so many
spider-man until we discover the
multiverse is still around and they were
all trying to go home yeah yeah but like
what's the big picture thing here
because Marvel already did this to a
degree with Marvel now they were like
okay like we're bringing back Carol
Danvers you're bringing given Magneto of
his own comic we have all new x-men like
we're gonna take the x-men from like an
alternate reality and we're gonna bring
him to this main reality and they're all
gonna be the younger version of
themselves like they did all that and so
they said don't breed like 50 years
where the comics just like read this
like start right all right but the
problem
is that for the most part it's just not
that interesting no problem like oh I'm
sorry I'm just gonna say like Marvel now
like the real problem like the real
ultimate failing with Marvel now is that
it's just not great like it's just not
import it's just not impressive it's not
interesting and like I don't know what
the problem is I'm it might be just the
character or the the creator combos it
could be the the direction it could be
the the need to tie everything into
those into events but for whatever
reason like you know it's just it's not
consistent and it's not interesting like
even Amazing Spiderman I'm a die-hard
spider-man fan the first nine issues
amazing spider-man for me really boring
like Oh an auger if they've entire
having an issue with the tying it into
everything you know and it doesn't even
make sense half the time you're like why
is this supposedly an original sin event
why is this an access that doesn't make
any sense but here's what I think is
going in and I think it has nothing to
do with wanting to tell a good story I
think it has nothing to do with the
movies it's nothing to do that yeah and
the early tooth it's starting with the
88 DC discovered that when they do a
crisis and announced they're relaunching
everything that it gives them a boom in
sales because everyone's like oh we're
gonna jump on board yes oh the 90s
killed comics in general we all know
this right mm-hmm
DC entered the 2000 I doing a bleep
infinite or thought crisis but it was
like 2001 or something that first was
the second one happen didn't it I was
like early in the 2000s a second one
happened the mid-90s was zero hour and
then after that it might have been
identity crisis
yeah but what I'm saying is that every
every three or four years DC has a
earth-shattering we're changing
everything event yep and the biggest one
that they've ever done was the new 52 it
was so big that Marvel said Margalo one
year later is happening right but
doesn't mean he's but it doesn't mean
anything they didn't nobody what but
what it did was it gave us a bunch of
number ones and everyone I think oh I
can start reading now and I think cuz DC
is going through the same crap they're
gonna have it that I mean unless you're
stupid not reading you know Multiversity
and that's - because they really only
happen at four books but unless unless
you're unless you're blind is what I
should say unless you're blind you're
not paying attention or whatever was
talking about DC's going the same route
they're gonna reboot everything
oh yeah I think I think on a business
standpoint what both of these companies
have now realized same thing video game
companies picked up on about six months
six years ago you can get more people
following your stuff if you reboot and
relaunch as opposed to just continuing a
story that's gonna take place you want
to go on a great example even me
super comic book guy that spends about
$40 a week on books yeah I missed
Inhumans I I got the first two issues
and just I just didn't neglect it to
grab it many a whole lot okay but we're
like on issue 9 now and so I went to the
comic book store and I was like oh crap
I totally forgot about the humans what
are we up to Jason's like we're on
number nine and I'm like I don't feel
like reading three three I'm not gonna
read it that's it and I think that's the
problem bobbles running into comic books
in general or not are they're not as big
of a market as the superheroes
themselves are oh yeah superheroes do
better sales on videogames and movies
and they've discovered that they can get
a surge in sales every time the reboot
crap well I think that's more of a
problem with like writing like that's
the problem Marvel has like it used to
be Marvel would come out with good
stories like relatively consistently but
now it's like every once in a while you
get a really good story like you get
house of him and then you get Civil War
and then you get Secret Invasion and
then you just get crap for like seven
years yeah and then you get axis which
is pretty decent so far and then it just
kind of goes that way oh don't don't
give me that that's what it is good it
will be forever evil like it is turning
into forever yeah with the bad guys the
problem with the problem I think is
going on right now for both companies is
they have too many books yeah instead of
consolidating down to some really good
stories of some really good writers
they've decided to just mass flood the
market with who has more books Marvel or
DC let's just launch new ones every week
now that is a great idea that actually
Ethan brought up on one of our shows we
I think was off the camera though but it
was the idea of like why does DC publish
so many titles what do we have sleaze
Batman books well like well because they
sell but like why are you making like
why is there an Aquaman and the others
book
why is there a cetana book
like why not brick because like the the
the actual the discussion was back when
Marvel filed for bankruptcy in like 96
there was some concern that like Marvel
might get bought by Warner Brothers and
then just get folded in with their
publishing label but the theory the
popular theory was that like they
wouldn't just merge the universes and be
like oh [ __ ] this is crazy they were
they would actually probably just
diminish the titles to like the main
floor and then just and then just
publish them and call it Marvel like
just oh yeah there was a discussion
about they were just gonna shrink it all
down to you see spider-man x-men you
know it wasn't an Avengers at the time
and then like what they could do is
rotate certain characters like this
month or this this during this like two
or six months span we're gonna put out a
moon night miniseries or a MS Marvel
miniseries or a daredevil miniseries and
if it sells like hotcakes then you just
keep it going or you collect it in a
volume and then you release it like in a
trade or in a hardcover form III think
you know we're kind of moving on to
something bigger here but I think that
that's gonna be the future of the
country see it's like having four main
titles and then just kind of rotating
out one book every couple of years and
like maybe making like some other books
like digital exclusives or online only
is like none of them have broken into
web comics at all which is kind of weird
cuz like look at like jl8 we talked
about this I'm sure before the the Yale
Stewart like Justice League team like
where they're liberal year-olds it's a
great comic it's fanfiction for the most
part because like he's not sanctioned by
DC DC has every right and every ability
to just call him up one day and say it's
over like you're done but it turned off
like take it all down you can't do it
why won't they just give him $50 a week
and then put jl8 on DC comm I take the
current state of you dig the Marvel
Comics and like i i've throw this all on
the shoulders of Cassatt
alright and here's why Kassadin took the
Marvel Knights imprint and removed it
yes alright and he rolled it into the
main earth-616 universe if the Marvel's
not Marvel Knights imprint was still
around it would be the perfect thing and
the reason why is because instead of
having like Magneto and a solo series
which I don't think they need to have
instead of having like you know miss
Marvel in her solo series like salsa
which I don't want you to have or
Captain model you could just have you
know Marvel Knights Captain Marvel and
you could say well it's kind of part of
the earth-616 universe but it's kind of
not it's a standalone story you know
that was the best thing about the Marvel
night it's like volume 2 of the Inhumans
to this day the best story ever
involving the Inhumans it was Marvel
Knights
it was standalone it was not considered
to be like the main part of the
mainstream continuity and it didn't need
to be because it was an isolated story
involving only the Inhumans and some
other like some normal humans and so on
and so forth but the fact remained that
Marvel could easily have turned the
Marvel Knights Inhumans had said fine if
you guys want to see magneto when its
own comic
you'll get Marvel Knights it's not you
tied into everything that's going on
with everything else but you'll be able
to see magneto off doing his own thing
when you're wondering what it is that
he's doing when he's not fighting the
x-men like that would have been a really
cool story you know or they could have
made like Marvel Knights all-new x-men
more we'll need to take a page at a DC's
book here because DC actually I mean I
love my DC books but they've done a lot
of stupid crap printing here's a DC does
a great thing where every week we every
day to week we get a digital issue of
something um if you go to their website
they have digital issues we have like
the injustice book started there now
it's a fully fledged comic we had value
at 66 start there and now it's a
full-fledged comic and what they do is
if the comic doesn't do too well on the
web they never print it and if it does
well on the web now with a reprint the
whole thing and then continue it on
comics and yeah is now on series 3 um
where is it oh yeah it's like series 3
and that started as a webcomic
that's why you cease doing yeah and they
basically anything they're iffy about
they test the waters over there now I
don't know why Aquaman and the others
didn't end up on that stupid web cuz
that book it's alright this okay just so
you know what acumen goes with others is
Rob that is Aquaman who really
established his team before the JLA now
here's the difference his team before
the Justice League
is nobody's yeah literally they invented
a team for him by the way I was talking
to my comp book retailer about that book
because he was like Aquaman and the
others it just sounds like Aquaman and
the rest and who are they it doesn't
matter I'm like you know good cool what
would've been really great for that book
if they had cuz like cuz you know they
they make teams and it's like who cares
like they have like the the defenders
and like on Netflix the defenders are
gonna be the New Avengers like but who
cares that the defenders are not that
team like you know who cares that the
defenders in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe won't be Silver Surfer dr.
strange old and died and you know other
people name of the Sonoran area yeah
like so for DC and Aquaman's book why
didn't they call it Aquaman and the
outsiders and then cuz to change the
name because the outsiders we use to be
Batman in the outsiders and actually
just be the outsiders in Batman like a
Red Hood nas wrote in The Outlaws right
now yeah it's right hood in the outlaws
but like why didn't they do Aquaman in
the Outsiders like because we are this
is a great name no it's a terrible name
because it just sounds like Aquaman and
the rest like you might as well have a
team or it's Aquaman and blood wind and
Blue Beetle and Booster Gold like where
it's like oh wow but value a nice
trusting interesting book then Aquaman
and I think it's the prisoner of the
voice I have no idea who these
characters are well that was the same
kind of problem ran into with the
defenders like like the only time I ever
remember that offenders being important
was during like Marvel's the end
storyline when Thanos captured the heart
of the universe like like tell me a
situation that you would need where the
Davinder like where you would need the
defenders like I mean I mean tell me a
situation like like you don't like the
Avengers can't stop them the really good
we should that's a great segue but
really quick there was a really good
defender series for like crap it was
back like in the in that Brittany and
the new aversion under the defenders
unless something that someone else was
back in 1940's and showed like Captain
America with the Human Torch and total
that's invaders
okay the original no the defenders was a
black enamel er says it's Aquaman and oh
those guys I guess yeah
the defenders were was a really really
cool book that came out from 2011 to
2012 and it was it was drawn by the
Dodson's like Terry and his wife Dodson
and I think Matt Fraction wrote it and
it had like a team of like Doctor
Strange the Silver Surfer red she-hulk
ant-man oh yeah that was a doctor yeah
that was dr. strange
he brought the defenders back after he
yeah powers back yeah it was very cool
and it was really sad that it ended at
issue 12 yeah Terry thoughts and on meds
drew it and it was really tight like it
was just and it was like damn like what
I really can it was by the way really
epic in scope and like they I think they
wound up like dealing with the end of
the world it was really cool
but anyway it's sad to see that end and
but like Aquaman should not have a team
called the other guys it should be cold
steel another team name because it
doesn't matter its new 52 the outsiders
could be the team of nobodies you want
to by the way DC stop trying to [ __ ]
make me read books about characters I
don't care about like like who wants to
read a book about Aquaman and like the
prisoner like I'm barely read Nakhla man
I'm gonna read the prisoner
dude you you within two seconds thought
of a better team and then I but Aquaman
and they it was a crime and Blue Beetle
Booster Gold you know who would love to
see that anybody who read comics 1997
which is everyone who reads comics right
now so like yeah they would have loved
to see that they would love to see blood
wind be a superhero yeah and have him be
on a team with Aquaman because everyone
already accepts an Aquaman super awesome
and grad so whatever like let him run
that team and like let his star power
draw people in and like fire and ice you
know for the record the guy that they've
got playing Aquaman I've you guys do you
know what it is right Jason Momoa was
either it was heat owning no he was the
guy
play dumb drogon I think his name was in
Game of Thrones he's like the big beefy
like I'm gonna kill everyone guy I know
I know
it'll be another show Rob we'll catch up
on attending eaters from now I want to
see Rob I want to see I want to see Rob
I want to see your opinion I want to see
an official dialogue opinions once you
get to the ending of lost Aquaman is
rather played call a Khal Drogo in Game
of Thrones
I kept it RZA name here you say that I
just said that's why I said we'll give
it drums oh no that's Justin hardly all
right all right he was Conan but okay so
since whale topic now I think we can all
agree on this secret Wars 2015 Marvel
has a crap ton of multiverses out there
a crap ton of stuff going on and we all
agree that it's all gonna collide the
one giant event that we're all gonna
hate and they're all gonna fight each
other and as long as they have a really
good artist on it it'll be kind of fun
to watch yeah I never thought I'd like
to see Olivia Qu'Appelle draw
spider-verse but it's gorgeous it's
really good oh thanks Haley they need to
go to jail E and say well Paley drawing
Secret Wars would be awesome that would
be Emily now last question I have for
you - yeah is Secret Wars in the lead to
a brand new toy line I mean we already
have the return of apocalypse with with
axis so like we're gonna get like
apocalypse toys and then there's like
the Age of Apocalypse toys which by the
guy by the way those of you guys that
never watched X been the animated series
in the 1990s when we get to age of
apocalypse you're gonna have so many
flashbacks and so many great memories
you guys are gonna love it but anyway
yeah 80 of the DC line so DC on the side
know about toys thing real fast DC has a
line of toys or they have an action
figure and like a $20 action figure for
every character in the DC and is
initially supposed to be the Seven
Justice League guys and that was going
to be in it and with Darkseid in it
sold so well but they have not stopped
while I fell into that trap and I now
have 70 of those guys all throughout my
house to the point where I literally had
to go to Jason - they look like we're
now doing toys about Justice League dark
and Teen Titans I don't care anymore
okay topic next topic we had was big
hero 6 comes out ain't over here I'm
sure it's going out everywhere and I'm
gonna see you're going to see I was
gonna go see some yeah big hero 6 but
the problem with big hero 6 is it's a
comic series that I said - miniseries
they've shown up as a cameo in like only
three books I think it was a Alpha
Flight at the Spider Man book they're in
they were in Spider Island the Spider
Island um there and other than that
that's it big that's they'd look I've
got the video sitting it's gonna launch
when we're done here
but they've literally not been in
anything there is no history to big hero
6 as a matter of fact there's such a
small amount of history that Disney
Pixar has completely rewritten the
almost non-existent history that they
have yes big hero 6 appeared in like 29
or 30 issues of comics they had their 5
issue solo series and then they had like
a 2 issues limited series after that yep
they've always been popular people have
always liked a bit Marvel refuses to
reprint them so you never had a big hero
6 comics now in big hero 6 - comics
they're actually a superhero team
originally led by silver samurai from
from Wolverine and a Sunfire one of the
x-men and they eventually pulled
together a bunch of superheroes and they
all go fight they a villains such as the
Amur Wraith which is a villain made up
of the spirits of all the people who
died in Nagasaki World War 2 the nuclear
bombers and it's made up of other
characters across Japan and Japan to
answer to the Avengers the money the
movies version I've never big brain acts
as a giant robot that turns into a
dragon a baymax um and the movie version
there are a bunch of college students
who are super geniuses who come together
to fight against the kabuki mask guy I
know who he is but he's not ever rate
they're not gonna do that on a Disney
Pixar
it's not even on earth they live in a
city called San Fran ochio and you're
like yeah they're not even a Japanese
team no a Japanese government team you
know why Marvel or why uh Disney is
making a movie called big hero six
because I had to look up who the big
hero hero six were after Disney
announced that they were making that
movie it's like who the hell is big hero
six you know I got when I wouldn't
looked it up and I was like okay they
appeared in 30 issues okay I understand
why Marvel is not gonna be doing
anything with a big hero 6 anytime soon
well it's also not theirs like they like
Marvel let Disney do it but it has no
like affiliation with the company nor is
it a Marvel Disney co-venture it's more
like a Disney venture that Marvel let
them use so like or rather it's a
venture that Disney went about as a
consequence of buying it so like part of
their part of Marvel's approach to big
hero 6 right now is like to treat it
like x-men or Fantastic Four which is to
say don't help it let them do whatever
they're gonna do
don't make any affiliation or connection
with it which i think is really kind of
a shame because they're all one company
now big hero 6 could be really big I
haven't read any reviews but the guys
are directed Ralph did it and recommend
is effing great if you've seen that song
I like like there's there's I can't go
anywhere without hearing I asked my
sister about that like I was like
explain to me like the song let it go
yeah frozen I was like why is it so
popular she's like oh because it's a
good song no ok so but yeah like it
makes sense to me that Disney's gonna do
big hero 6 because obviously if Marvel
was going to do anything with big hero 6
even in just comic books they would have
done it with Marvel now so they're not I
mean there's no reason for them to do
anything with big hero 6 when was the
last time silver samurai was relevant
I mean this is New Avengers in nineteen
2004 yeah it was supposedly killed by a
lecture of one what I actually learned
that when doing my video for a big hero
6 which which was funny cuz I did the
video for big hero 6 I learned about all
this great history about them and that
got me excited to see the movie tonight
this is like a kid's version of the
Power Rangers what they could have done
was they could have done the power pack
which is a Disney like it's not easy but
it's like it would it's so up their
alley it's so 3 eyes just it's literally
a shoe it's literally comic about a
bunch of children who are brothers and
sisters who have superpowers they become
superheroes and it's like you shouldn't
be going anywhere being super here
you're like eight like it's like if Bart
and Lisa we're superheroes like it's no
you know what it's like it's it's like
um if Maggie not even Maggie I'm like
I'm ditching the Simpsons I'm thinking
like uh that show the Brady Bunch
it's like at the Brady Bunch we're
superheroes it's really weird yeah and
like a like a white unicorn or like a
white horse like I cover what his name
is like I want to say the white Mane's
but that's from Skyrim I can't remember
yeah but it's like what a weird team a
to create but be like what a great idea
for Disney to do something with it but
then what we did with big hero 6 which
is still cool and I'm gonna give it I'm
gonna reserve judgment I heard that
there are a lot of Marvel references in
it really yeah now I heard those marbles
not making any effort to connect with
them but they apparently the animation
team couldn't resist amid a lot of
Marvel jokes you have to pay attention
to catch them and apparently they're
mostly in one like kids bedroom like one
of the biggest nerds has like all this
Marvel stuff I don't know I'm looking
forward to seeing it but honestly as
much as I like the fact that this is
separate I you know I thought it could
have been like a guard as the galaxies
think that right there just reaffirms my
thought it would have been epic if it
just even loosely linked into the mobile
universe just like yes they exist there
there we know about big hero 6 but I
want it to be connected because I want
to see them make it doesn't even have to
be connected with the Marvel Cinematic
in fact it'd be weird and confusing if
they did but if they only see the Disney
XD universe the ultimate spider-man
universe I know like but they they could
do so much with it and like I think
everyone has been hoping when Marvel was
first bought by Disney that they were
gonna do like a Disney Pixar kind of
adaptation and because their animation
they can do whatever they want they
could make any story they want they
could have spider-man in the Avengers
all be friends and make movies and stuff
as long as its animated but number one
this isn't Pixar this is Disney's
separate animation studio that they
created when they thought they were
gonna lose Pixar it's the same studio
that made like tangled and wrecker
Alfred frozen has no affiliation with
Pixar whatsoever it's not it's Pixar has
their own Pixar's their own group and
then when Pixar was like we're good
we're ditching DS we're edition Disney
we don't need them Disney was like quick
make a CG studio and they hobbled
together this animation studio they made
bolt and tangled and wreck-it Ralph was
on the docket and then Pixar was like
okay I guess we're friends again so now
they at least two redundant animation
studios what bolt made me cry I didn't
see I was so sad why are you watching
kids movies man you was a dog I thought
he was just superhero any owner he
thought he's the owner he got rid of him
he thought you'd like they literally had
a scene where bolt was like she doesn't
want me she's throwing me to the curb I
have to go live on my own and it was the
saddest thing ever
it's really cool man like you've been
seen and by the way rob has not seen
wreck-it Ralph which is no I haven't
seen what are you it's one of the best
animated movies I've seen in years
yeah but I don't work said that he was
like man you got to go see record it's
great it's the Gears of War universe
that's like amazing they go into the
Gears of War universe well it's a bit
severe I mean how deep could they really
go in the Gears of War universe and it's
like a yeah and there's no killing bugs
every
bug guts going everywhere it's awesome I
mean like the same thing with Runaways
Runaways would be a really great
animated movie or TV show
I think Feige has bigger plans for
Runaways I think they want to make it
into like a like a show yeah I wasn't
saying somebody was talking about that
you know but the last time they made it
they made the last time that Marvel
tried to make a show about a young team
they made this this pilot movie which is
supposed to be launched for a TV show
called Generation X I don't know if
anybody remembers Generation X from the
90s but it was the team that Jubilee was
in charge of and it had such faith such
wonderful chestnut characters like skin
and hast chamber
just these great characters they were
they used to be called they're called
cannon fodder then the characters that
you put up in the front lines so what I
like that he kills all those characters
and then you avenge them with your
stable characters like a storm and
Wolverine cycle I want to be named that
but like Generation X was this it was
you need.if guys in the chat and guys
who I'm talking to right now
when this is over go to youtube and type
in Generation X movie and you will see
some of the worst stuff ever because
like they had no money they didn't laid
no budget but they were all mutants and
they all the super powers so you they
had to like reserve like they you know
they're like oh I'm gonna do powers oh I
can't do it right now though cuz cause
too much oh my god good just the cover
to the Generation X movie looks like
1980s it's like in like blossom like
remember the show blossoms friend's name
Awesome's name no no her friends blossom
I knows I know her name was blossom but
what was her friend's name like no I
mean like blossoms friends name I don't
know yeah yeah I can trip gosh I had the
biggest crush on her back in the day
that not blossom but the friend no I
thought wasum had a too big of a nose
you could watch it for you watch a
streaming I don't know if you could
download it yeah oh my god this does
this
like a looks like a cover for New Kids
on the Block I assumed about six
yes that's what her name was yes we're
completely off of the big hero six but
in general I think we get I think we can
all agree when it comes to being hero
six that yes there are so many better
teams that they could have actually used
instead of just taking the big hero six
name oh well that said I think the big
hero stick is a great idea I think it'll
be really cool I love some of the
changes they made for example I love
baymax has changed
I look at honey lemons change honey
lemon was like more like she was opposed
to like a teenager but she looked like a
30 year old sex goddess and now she's
like kind of a bookworm and I'm like and
a kid and I'm like that's cool like good
for you for not like overly sexualizing
any of these characters well yeah honey
lemon was like a secret agent like yeah
and I'm not in fact when I made the
thumbnail for the video the one that's
gonna go live I had to blow up images of
the characters to make the thumbnail
yeah a honey lemons image she literally
has blush on her boobs and I was like
why are her boobs blushing yeah it's
really weird she but but like that
change is really great so I'm really
excited about what they're gonna do a
big hero six and here's the best part of
it if big hero six goes over like
gangbusters and they know that Marvel is
associated and affiliated with it it
opens the door for so much more
yeah I mean like okay like what do I
mean what are we talking about because I
think I like your idea I'm power packed
because power pack would be a good way
for marble to like segue young kids yes
the Marvel Cinematic Universe and so you
have like I mean I don't want to see
like power pack like toddlers I don't
know three year old kids running around
with 13 13 15 a Runaways animated movie
would be really cool especially if they
treated it a little bit like more like
The Incredibles instead of like
wreckit-ralph wrecker Alf is really
awesome but it's more like it's more
geared for kids even though it's like
Auto delt themes but Incredibles is like
the first Pixar movie where they were
like that's for people who are over 15
like it's it's for its fur I mean you
could do runaways cuz though you're
talking about like Ultron's kid
and hopefully nothing was one of the
runaways I was scroll who looked like a
hoe yeah yeah so you're talking about
like characters are you can presumably
do face oh wait I'm sorry that's not
that you're thinking of The Young
Avengers which is oh yes because that
they need to do Young Avengers no they
don't they need to do is actually make
it better don't need Young Avengers you
need a really good Young Avengers team
recently they have you read The
Children's Crusade no it's great ok I
haven't read Young Avengers it's great
and it builds directly off of House of M
really it explains why Scarlet Witch you
love the house and I know my Scarlet
Witch we're crazy but ya know you're not
going I'm going you don't know because
it's in the Children's Crusade oh my god
you know what I will go and read the
stupid good I own it I'll go would lend
it to you but I'm I want to read it
again it's really great it's got Jim
Cheung on our convenient hey I would
totally loan it to you but I've had this
book for ever and I just I want to read
it right now to you but no really I
should say is I'm not gonna loan to you
I will check out Young Avengers it's
really good it's called Avengers The
Children's Crusade it's not called Young
Avengers because they knew that no one
would buy that just call that Avengers
the children person alright really cool
and it's got everybody in it it's got
the Avengers it's got the x-men it's got
Doctor Doom and we find it like the ha
there's so much in it I don't want to
ruin it
no don't ruin it all go back and read it
it's time people in the chat are gonna
start screaming at me oh yeah well it's
time for our last topic and sounds most
favorite book ever exes I think axis is
good I like axis so far I mean it picks
up in the middle of pandemonium yeah
like everything is going crazy and read
on sloths just annihilating everybody
apocalypse is back man no it's not evil
apocalypse which I'm disappointing out
hold on now issued a wooden addition
before coming out yeah so alright so
here's my question yeah okay so that's
apocalypse because that's what I was
looking for was a planning turn on it
yes okay yeah cuz they were showing that
on the at the end of issue number three
so yeah he walked out nobody wasn't evil
he just walked up was like we're gonna
resolve this you know I want to see evil
but it ended with Deadpool hogging him
bein like avid you grew up but he's like
don't touch me oh yeah which which III
want to see I want to see evil plug like
we know he's gonna be there because when
death walk or whatever his name was was
like looking to the future of all these
different characters like when they when
when the whole thing first started yeah
when they brought back like Evan like he
looked at his future but he wouldn't
tell him what it was and then you
learned that like his future he's just
gonna be like killing everybody
basically like apocalypse is gonna come
back and just lay waste to everybody so
that's what I want to see I want to see
apocalypse come back and just wreak
havoc people just wreck every just
Records man I just want to see
apocalypse come back on record Ralph man
I want to see you just hear it all up I
would like to see have we ever seen the
Hulk fight the apocalypse cuz I would
love to see that yes there was that
there were a couple of instances there
was one like ever what story was what it
was when apocalypse had made the
Incredible Hulk his horsemen death and
like like he physically restrained him
that's cool
yeah I know they're doing Thanos versus
Hulk which is gonna be cool that that is
something that people have been looking
forward to for a long time like the
closest you ever got to that was when
was the Infinity Gauntlet when when the
two of them were going against each
other but you had the Hulk and you had a
drock's a destroyer but it wasn't unlike
they didn't tell you if it was like the
most enraged the whole cuz you smart
Hulk yeah I want to see like world
breaker Hulk against Thanos is what I
want to see like at his strongest point
ever
so well I mean every point you guys just
brought up but as far as axis goes yes I
here's my opinion on this and I'm on
both your sides with this Sal I think
this is a horrendous Marvel book oh god
my point
can I stay you can stay your point I'm
sorry I think it's an amazing DC book
because it throws all of their
superpowers into it just an arena
basically and they just
each other and we'll have 21 pages of
Superman just fist fighting with
Brainiac and there's nothing the simple
part of text that's what axis is it's
like a joke from Deadpool here four
pages of everyone get destroyed yeah 20
start making a joke
four more pages of people getting
destroyed it's it's a great deal getting
destroyed in the worst ways to like you
have like Tony Stark who at some point
along the line made like adamantium
sentinels Tony sorry you just gave me
these adamantium senticles that you made
amazing isn't it yeah I wonder thing
about that I was like my god Tony Stark
like you drunk [ __ ] get himself drunk
on bet on a bender just go to get drunk
and create Adam NTM Sentinels like that
doesn't make any sense why wouldn't
alter on of grab those back during age I
mean there are so many times that a
villain would have taken away ultron
like with his Ultron robots was able to
just wreak havoc on the world I mean he
didn't need those several things really
yeah because he in the end he doesn't
always lose having some adamantium
sentinels would not have helped him in
any ways everyone I mean he didn't lose
because of like an like because he was
overpowered he lost because they
reprogrammed him right but they would
never have gotten there if he had
adamantium stencils what we're stating
is every villain in the world would he
use these sittings
yeah fine if that's what you want to be
yeah it's it's yes that's one of the
inconsistencies and I don't like about
like Marvel events like that's one of
the things I don't get like I'm not I'm
not Curran issue number four somebody in
the chat mentioned something about Nick
Fury is Nick Fury back with issue number
four how did you get there like how did
that
there's good guy carnage yes explain
that that's that's the kind of
inconsistency that I don't dig like but
if these so these adamantium robots have
just been sitting around for so long
then what is like why didn't anybody
ever anywhere use them how long were
they sitting there
why does like break him out during fear
itself when Serdar was destroying
everything and he turned to alcoholism
to try and get Odin why not have him
doing like siege ordering yeah he's
getting drunk right there his carnage
literally became a good guy he's
swinging around going the whole time
saying things like oh I don't know why
do these feelings but I won't I want to
save people they flipped him that's what
they did that's that's what they they
flipped everyone yeah Xavier is in
Georgia Red Skull now I'm assuming but
Tony Stark's becoming a drunk again
there's a whole scene in which Spiderman
was beating up somebody and I guess he's
gone evil carnies is now the good guy
he's gonna stop spider-man like one of
the things that I didn't like a whole
lot with with axis was it was apparently
alright we know about the batch story of
on alright when you're reading a comic
book and suddenly like onslaught shows
up or people start talking about on site
like oh my god shit's really gonna get
bad because you're talking about a super
uber powerful character and it's got
like the mental powers of Xavier and the
powers of magneto combined into one
somehow
Quentin choirs just sitting behind a
wall keeping like red on slots mind
confined so that he can't get into
anybody else I'm like okay this is the
most relevant quit enquires ever been
since like schism maybe yeah and that's
it and he started a riot during shield
so I mean like this is the most relevant
he's ever been so you know whatever
because I know how much raw south hates
these things the middle of this book is
nine advertisements for others other
comics yeah that's one thing that drives
me nuts I mean about like Skyy yeah I'll
be rushing to the store for that one
wait a minute
Benny what what I like agents of shield
sir I love agents of shield but I'm not
really gonna be on the show that nobody
likes nobody watches that show it's I
think all three of us can agree that we
enjoyed the show especially with the
latest season yeah yeah but no I it's
doing horrendous flash is killing it in
ratings flash is amazing arrows really
doing that well in the ratings
flash flash is CW's biggest show period
ever biggest launch ever honestly man
watching the pilot I didn't think it'd
turn out that way I'm surprised you just
kind of amazing to me yeah
but um I don't know I mean I don't think
access is bad I think access they're
doing access in like phases so the
potential for it to get better is there
but so far sure and leave something to
be desired like I never really imagined
the idea of like a red onslaught so that
was kind of cool but at the same time
like I can't say that like onslaught and
Red Skull combined into one is anything
like wow it's not mind-blowing what
apocalypse is back and that's my that's
my thing right there right so that's
that's my Home Slice so I'm really
excited to see what's gonna happen with
apocalypse back in the in the whole
situation there's a chat agrees the
flash is an amazing show and you should
be watching it Rob really flash is
amazing the show is awesome the comic
would suck I like the show arrow but
this season like season 2 is great for
arrow 3 is kind of Dragon right now we
don't really see that much of a goal
other than dealing with what's happening
yeah all right so so one last topic
before we before we call it a night is
since we were talking about agents of
shield how current is everybody current
up until they do their 75th anniversary
video whatever it was yeah
okay what do we think about Skye thank
you like as a character yeah and like
Coulson doing his drawings oh that's
cool you know I mean
like what's your like this is it's not
like this is day I'm like I'm not like
annoyed like I think it's cool I mean I
guess if you can call it I'm intrigued
I'm like oh I'm not even a treat and I
think part of the reason for that is is
we really know where this is going
we know who know it could be anything
they're saying like people are
speculating could be the terrigen bomb
but it still it still linked to the
Inhumans is what's going on you know yes
because they expects them to shoehorning
Inhumans but like I don't know what else
I think it a shoehorn in big hero six
part two could you imagine that a TV
show it's a big hero six on there also
oh we're the amazing you better believe
in then be the most incredible thing
anybody's ever going to see no I don't
know I mean to me the idea of the whole
sky thing is kind of intriguing and I
think they're gonna go in the direction
of the Inhumans but we don't know I mean
yeah all we have is just some kind of
obelisk and nobody really knows what's
gonna have it with I mean they said in
humans that's come on later on down the
line and humans may I mean I'm pretty
sure Inhumans will be introduced
sometime between now or sometime between
Captain America 3 and age of Ultron but
like for me it'd be interesting to see
them go but what could they what could
they really do in a tas of shield to
like take it towards the direction of
Inhumans how could they write that in I
mean you know you don't have to bring
the Inhumans in in a big way doesn't
have to be black bolt and Medusa on the
craft as a matter of fact if you allow
everyone cuz he Inhumans while they've
always been there no one in the universe
really acknowledges or seems to know
they exist yet until they show up so you
could very easily be like oh look
there's the Inhumans and then that leads
into the Black Bolt and Medusa movie
definit very easily that's nice and then
we discover that the Indians have been
here the whole time
Anat ileum has been floating over Alaska
we didn't know I mean here's your the
thing to like like is it could it be a
tear Jim Bob because if you guys are
right and it is the terrigen bomb they
could just be taking like the any what
is it in humanity storyline yeah I'm
saying well the T region bomb goes off
and all these Inhumans start activating
all the little right they could do that
and um the movie is gonna be about how
because the Inhumans have now surfaced
on the surface
blackbolt a'mma duce at all that have
been living in secret this whole time
now they come out and they discover at
Illya and they launch it in the Dow
there in the universe you know yeah now
they're saying the big thing with with
respect to sky is like clearly the
biggest reveal is going to be linked to
her identity and this is the first time
that like like anything the most recent
episode they said that sky isn't her
real name which thank God because and
why is it her name dream or cloud and
I'm like oh good it's fake
so like the fact that like it isn't her
name and they've expressly said like
that's not her name like as if to say to
the audience like but you're gonna ship
bricks when you find out who it is like
that I think that's the big reveal I
don't even think that the obelisk is I
think the album's gonna be cool but I
don't I think the big reveal will be who
sky actually is do you think it'll be
someone huge or anything it'll be like a
minor in humans well I think it'll be
more like it'll be as big as putting
Mockingbird in the show like that's how
big the carrot goes oh I don't think so
yeah I mean okay that's cool she's in
the show but the only one that didn't
care about Mockingbird but like I think
that number one it's cool that she's in
the show number two it's cool that they
cast an actress who could make the leap
to movies I'm not saying that they're
gonna start making that movie but if
they decide to make like a Hawkeye movie
one day and they want to put her in it
yeah no one's gonna be like but she's
some terrible TV actors they're like
she's good enough like she's she's gonna
be fine well the other half of this
equation is even if they choose to
introduce like when they bring the
Inhumans in and they choose to stage
them in are they even going to bring in
like the entire inhuman royal family not
like obviously we'll see lockjaw because
everybody wants hilarious that'll be the
whole show like the whole show is like
they mean like they can end the show
with like Skyy being in a human or some
crap and her being like what am I gonna
do now like shield closes and Coulson
dies or some crap and then like you know
Skye's all by ourselves think I know
what am I gonna do now and the lockjaw
shows up and then you just Wolf's and
then she they both disappear yeah
would be more epic if not only did
locked I'll show up but so did Vin
Diesel in the blackboard contacts like
does the end cameo and he's like God
that would blow people's mind no no way
he couldn't talk to people like we would
just he would be there with her or they
probably cast Medusa or something like
that like but yeah
next to quilok Joe and then she's like
who are you and then like lockjaw just
barks and then they both tell like that
all free teleport right well that's
Samuel Jackson show up in the last two
episodes of last season so Mike could we
have the Vin Diesel oh you said he's
happy to do it I think and he's all like
and like Samuel Jackson is obviously
back for for age of Ultron
oh yeah he's in the trailer yeah yeah
yeah he was something he was in the
freakin trailer so here's my question
if sky is going to be in and human do
you think she'd be crystal I mean like
crystal is choosing one the Mary
Quicksilver and there's also the one who
dated the Human Torch she's a big
character yeah character yeah she was
she could kind of segue she's like the
go-between for like the Inhumans and
like everybody else in the Marvel
Universe
she thought it makes friends she's like
the ambassador kind of yeah okay like
she sleeps around all the time yeah but
um she married Ron in the accuser
eventually during anihilation conquest I
think really yeah Andre said this guy's
father is mad Jim Jasper know excited
imagine Jasper's was I just want to see
him like start talking like a British
accent and just like start warping
reality inside yeah I mean so yeah this
guy's obviously probably gonna be an
inhuman we really don't know who no
she's not gonna be Skye yeah I mean I
agree I think it's cool where they're
going I just hope we don't drag it out
much longer that's one problem I think
agents of shield does have were it gives
you a good idea a good starter like the
first episode of Asians this year was
great and then it took 12 episodes to
get to something that was good
yeah you know yeah it took them a while
to finally get onboard but they said
they learned from that they said that
this time around it's not gonna be
anywhere near like that I mean we've got
more superheroes we get or more villains
we have the absorbing man so there's
more like powerful people we have
blizzard
yeah so we I almost made a video bubble
isn't and then it realizes like no
information la blizzard I would just
well I mean there's I would say even
socio brought in blizzard because they
couldn't get ice man so yeah I don't
know but regardless like the one thing I
love about agencies do is that it's a
great way for them to like take small
steps to build up to something big yeah
and so I'm really hoping that this whole
crystal thing or this whole sky thing
will lead to like any her being crystal
or maybe even just like a random inhuman
who was separated from the inhuman
somebody said that like in the Chad that
like and this is the first time I
thought of it and blows my mind that
like her dad could be mr. Hyde who was a
great villain for the show that's true
and that sky is Daisy Johnson and that
would be totally okay with me Daisy
Johnson
Benny is a Bendis created character who
was originally modeled after the
angelina jolie character from hackers
mm-hmm but now that they can't afford
that like or you have her cuz she has to
be a kid like they threw that out but
she heard her nickname is quake and she
can create seismic like activity in like
pink with pinpoint accuracy she's like
she's a member of uh Nick Fury's secret
Avengers the Secret Avengers aren't very
secret every woman's a turn-on it I know
and now I'm pretty sure that's who she
is I'm a mom I'm on the hunt now that
you're like oh no I think is this
because I thought that because it's so
easy to use and you could transition him
to the to the daredevil show yeah I mean
I would like to give a turn out her dad
was Maximus the mad to be honest that
would be cool but I think ever it's over
they cast him yeah yeah I think they
have it's the guy that was like the evil
douchebag and Game of Thrones but since
you guys don't watch that you don't know
that is yeah watch Game of Thrones man
oh do you yeah the guy who cut off the
other guys oh yeah your team came out
what's his name you talk about uh I
could never get through it I could never
get us some you talk about the dude the
the son yeah it's great everyone and
then he ended up being chained down and
he became like basically what's his name
wrecker
wretch or something like that and they
started calling him the guy who cut off
his Winkie yeah yeah yeah and then he
made him pinky was eaten it's
thank God Game of Thrones are so good
man oh yes he's from the silver I think
it's like the silver islands or whatever
I read somewhere that he's on the the
big great Maximus the mad oh yeah since
we're talking about even shows I do want
to do it there's one last hot topic that
got announced six days ago at this point
okay uh CBS has greenlit the Supergirl
TV show yes is now going to is now
casting it don't care I'm not seeing it
do you guys just see this as being a
Gilmore Girls version of super a
Smallville is it basically what we're
gonna get I think I think the problem
that you have here and this is why I
like the Marvel Universe automatic
universe so much
I think Marvel Cinematic Universe are
playing some stuff by ear but like foggy
or whatever his name is they sat down
and said here's where we want to be in
like ten years
oh yeah I think that like with all these
DC characters and all these networks
they're like oh my God look how popular
Marvel is and they're just like flying
by the seat of their no I agree with you
on the movies I think the movies they
are doing that because it seems like
every other day they're like we're gonna
make a movie the other universe right
yeah but the TV shows CW which by the
way it stands for CBS and Warner
Brothers and the TV the TV like universe
they've been slowly building upon and
using the success of previous shows to
go with further show Supergirl has been
in talks now for almost a year that they
were gonna possibly do it and with the
flash like being the biggest show on CW
I totally see that being why they're
doing it
yeah the the TV universe seems to be
very closely linked and it kind of
carefully planned the movies they're
literally like who's popular a movie I
mean that's well I mean even for me like
that's kind of how it seems that's kinda
how it seems with their show because
like like if I sit down and watch these
shows yes like flash and arrow were
connected like flashes in an arrow like
we know they share the same universe
yeah those are actually connected
yeah and with with Supergirl it may very
well be the same way but it seems as
though they yeah it didn't seem like
they sat down and they said okay like we
want to interconnect this
the huge universe it's like oh my god
the Marvel Cinematic Universe is doing
so well let's just let's just do
something like it I honestly wouldn't be
surprised
I wouldn't be surprised if somebody at
like Warner Brothers who's in charge of
those of the of the dispersion of those
franchises went oh you mean Supergirl
and the are those all the same
alright well whatever anyway well no
doubt whoever's in charge of
green-lighting Supergirl has no idea
that she's related to Superman or maybe
she's a sex toy for Superman as far as
he's concerned
well David where is the person who said
that and he does he is the main guy for
uh well see here's the problem that
we're having with it cuz a lot of these
shows even Constantine was talked about
as a CW thing and CW was developing this
universe yeah
now what it seems to be doing is CW is
trying to very carefully introduce
characters and create this universe and
NBC bought constitute it so it's almost
like Warner Brothers doesn't want to
wait to see if the guys who want to buy
it actually want to buy it not just to
sell it to whoever gets it now that's my
problem with Supergirl Supergirl was
being talked about as a CW franchise
play it's gonna launch next year is what
we were hearing that if flash did well
this year we would then have arrow
Supergirl and the flash they don't
appear now we hear that it's been picked
up by I want to say MBC again the guys
who own Constantine and that's not even
see if it was CBS I could at least see
okay you know what they own CW it's it's
an interlinked right if NBC's picked it
up not CW it is it is CBS by the way it
is CBS s it yep okay okay well then oh
then at least we're on assault okay
I mean that could still be interrelated
but that's the big question will it be
and is this just appearing on prime time
CBS or CW or Syfy cuz Syfy picked up the
rights to another show which apparently
I didn't know this but see that CBS owns
them also so yeah other stores being
interlink to wit the whole series the
whole universe that's what sci-fi is
doing a DC show too
which one do they go in I'll look it up
hold on see maybe it's maybe because
like I don't really read DC that this
isn't super exciting for me like for me
like knowing that like like Jessica
Jones and Luke Cage and daredevil are
going to be on Netflix
really exciting from yeah that's
exciting that's Booster Gold Oh cuz I F
I picked up Booster Gold great from the
network that brought you Frankenfish
comes of all the super nerves to get a
show that's the one that makes me go
what I mean they made shark attack three
Megalodon which you know it was exactly
what you think it is but but well I will
say this the TV show is even for marbled
with the agent Carter I think coming up
and I think starting up here soon yeah
the TV shows as far as DC goes seem to
be more better planet than the movies
it's almost like they're like here's our
TV Department here's our movie
Department these guys are all in the
same page these guys were hiring by the
day and they just they've read one
comment by the way that agent Carter
show looks really good that blows my
mind why it cuz it shouldn't be good
it's late it's also genius cuz it
doesn't have to link to anything they
can hear that show it could tank and
they could say well that's it genius
where they're doing it's just like
darting to the galaxy and big hero six
if they do well this opens the door for
more crap if it doesn't do well who the
Freak cares throat aside I think it's
gonna do rain well though because it's
good I think what it's gonna do is this
gonna like answer a lot of questions and
cover a lot of middle ground that Marvel
can go back to later on like what
happened between the time that Captain
America was like frozen and ice yeah and
then Captain America was found and
thought out okay see like young ant-man
yeah they can they can do that they can
bring in Hank Pym they can do all that
kind of stuff so that so what they can
do with agent Carter if they wanted to
or even if they wanted to touch back
into in the Marvel Cinematic Universe so
they can come back and they can say well
like yeah Tony Stark was drunk one day
and Hank Pym gave him the idea for
Ultron and so then like it resurfaced
again later on so right now I think
that's definitely gonna do yeah but all
those advertisements for like Pym
particles and stuff like all over the
place you know and all these different
things and stuff so a lot of people were
posting those all over the Marvel
subreddit so I don't know I'm pretty
excited to see how this how all this is
going to shape up but again
guys I don't really read DC and I'm not
like an avid DC reader that's probably
isn't why like I'm not there's a cat
well I agree doing that too and honestly
to someone who is a hardcore DC reader
and doesn't touch Marvel as far as
they're concerned at Marvel had success
and now they just won't shut the [ __ ] up
about their movies yeah I can totally
see I mean like it looks like DC is just
like enough with the marble stuff yeah
it's like Kat wants to know what's going
on well you know what you know what I
think honesty is going on with DC and
the TV shows i movies are pretty much
done like in barbara owns the superhero
movie market that's yeah DC is - gonna
try and jump in late I think DC sees the
TV market as well they've only done one
show we can beat them to the TV market
we can make any interconnected universe
lets him for like for me if DC was smart
they would have done the same thing the
Marvel did and hopped on Netflix because
Netflix gives you a lot more freedom as
much as I love DC these are the guys
that are also trying to make a very
large YouTube presence I mean knowing
knowing what DC's decision making like
ability is they probably team up with
like Yahoo you guys ever seen like those
who exclusive TV you know like four
minutes it looked like one of them it
looked like a TV Little House Christmas
Spectacular ya know like like TV Little
House Christmas Spectacular this is good
like that that show looked like ass like
watch know like this is the worst
trailer and I'm like this is supposed to
be the best bits of your show it's all
garbage yes we only will you spread your
cat for the love of God or picking up or
something it loves you it loves you like
it's like sorry he's like man you guys
yeah I guess I guess that that's a good
segue then to head off because now we're
going into crazy tangents about Netflix
and Hulu Plus so I'll go ahead and say
it's that Rob
for those guys who don't want us to end
we're not technically we're taking a
three-hour break we'll be back tonight
if you went to my channel you got to see
an interview with Stephan Stephan Frank
who is the writer and creator of the
book silver but he's also the guy who
created Iron Giant he's the guy who did
the Smurfs movie he's the guy who did
Despicable Me and he works for Sony
Pictures and tonight it's going to
definitely be myself and Rob talking
with him for about a half hour um Sal
will draw me but I'll try but for the
most part we're gonna be shooting we
shoot everything today at like post
eight o'clock so like it takes a couple
hours to shoot the show's back issues
itself takes like over an hour and we go
to Applebee's appetizers that was pretty
fun like that Applebee's it was pretty
awesome
apparently goes to Applebee's every
single time after he shoots and if
anybody who goes to Applebee's nose
that's when half-price appetizers just
kick in and so rather than get like a
meal for like $20 we each just split two
or three appetizers apiece and then we
have like a thirty dollar bill that
somebody pays everybody well here is the
funny part so we get there and I think
it was it was either
it was either Ben or Ethan one of them
made the joke we're gonna order
everything for the menu yeah we're gonna
get everything so the waiter comes over
and I live Alex there we go we'll take
it off what was the one thing like you
know we cannot tell a couple things the
nachos were always kind of a mistake oh
no we got the nachos a problem you know
it was it was a fun weekend it was a
good weekend weekend yeah but all right
guys so anyway um we're gonna go and
bring this podcast to an end but yeah
we'll be back up at a around 10 o'clock
or so maybe you know give or take a few
minutes here there but uh but yeah so I
know even done in a while Rob but you
typically end it with what are we all
doing in our channels so Rob Warfel
explained this week well
I've I've been debating on whether or
not I wanted to do this but we're
finally gonna get around to it we're
finally gonna do it we're gonna start
the Age of Apocalypse storyline with
Legion quest so now that'll be going on
for however long yeah yeah
which we actually got to do all the
lead-up so we're out to explain rogue
we're gonna have to explain mr. sinister
have to agree and we've kind of done
magneto in there and yeah it's gonna be
yeah it's gonna be fun that's exciting
and what's going on over at the little
house now sounds a over to cute little
house were shooting back issues tonight
off-the-rack we're reviewing amazing
spider-man number 9 velvet number 8 and
Superman unchained number 9 we're also
going to be I mean it depends really
with with back issues I haven't decided
which one I'm gonna do there are two
stories I would love to do fear itself
or age of Ultron I thought we did age of
Ultron but it turns out that was really
more of a tangent so we may dedicate a
we've all been doing this so long that
you don't even know what you've done I
thought I explained it already because
age of Ultron took like two minutes to
move read explained but like we're gonna
try it so age of Ultron and
unfortunately it's all gonna be on this
stupid thing cuz that's all I have like
I got a new one I got the new Galaxy Tab
oh nice I have just an iPad I have an
iPhone with a crock down screen yeah hey
talk to me after this I can say am i up
my old life owns I just upgraded to the
galaxy no no that's okay what's
happening get the screen fix for like 50
bucks or 60 bucks let's do it I'll sign
the iPhone and then put it up for
auction on eBay and I'll donate the
proceeds to charity dude that's gonna
sell for like 10 bucks alright so over a
comic story in IG I literally while we
were sitting here put out the big hero 6
know your universe I'm gonna be we're
finally bringing back Grand Slam and
indie Booker Soros on Sunday next week
is gonna be a no year universe on the
Illuminati I'm also going to be touching
on the incursians I'm gonna talk I'm
actually doing a complete story for that
the New Avengers
where we see the incursions and all and
stuff and I'm gonna do the next story in
the flash story arc while I prep up
Superman doomed but I want to plug and
it's what we should start plugging now
because everyone getting ready for it um
I'm gonna make the official announcement
here but we are launching a joint
operation known as the weekly pull net
yep you will be able to find the podcast
there weekly um along with a few other
podcasts that we're kind of putting
together amongst us um you'll be able to
find all of our shows upload it to a
central location so you can just enjoy
the latest episode for Marvel explain
jumped over to the latest video of comic
story yelling at you and then go chill
out with Sal where he's just hanging out
with Ben and Ethan and we're gonna be
opening the doors to people to submit
articles if you want to be a writer for
the website along with a form so we can
actually get all three of our
communities into one location so we
pulled net it is live right now but it
also is doing its modeling in the videos
where we kind of get everything worked
out they finished up yeah and there's
there's a couple people that I've seen
like there's a guy one of the
subscribers that I have a guy named
Andre that writes you know four that's
like articles or stuff like that so we
could do that but for this whole thing
for the weekly pulldown net guys that's
all Benny like Benny has been
spearheading this whole thing so so he's
been making sure it was all taken care
of he's been making sure the website is
getting sorted out and making sure that
all that stuff's copacetic so me and Sal
don't have to which is why I wanted to
bring up here what we're on a live
viewing in 115 people if you're
interested in writing for about comic
books and movies and geeky kind of stuff
go ahead and shoot us an email uh your
best bet would honestly be to tag all
three of us so I'm comic story at
gmail.com
he's Rob at Marvel explain calm and
that's Sal at TV little house little
house online those three males in the
chat so people know um shoot us an email
and we're gonna start like kind of
screening through some base articles
it'll be and we're actually discussing
the pile up basically compensation per
article kind of situation so we are
looking to build this community up get
some articles going and make this a
really good spearheaded location for
your comic book news yeah all the reason
I'm making the announcement here now is
I've had a few people even comments
about they get their information from
the weekly pulled on net even though
we've never announced it I don't know I
guess found it
yeah and and we just recently on that
video the Marvel gave us to put out
decided to go ahead and actually
announced it kind of in the subject
there so yeah yep so yeah yeah I mean so
we'll see in three hours everyone yell
at Sal to make sure he shows up yep make
it but I'm really feeling bad about that
you know let him know he's awesome Iron
Giant makes me cry every time I see it
so you know funny side note I was
cleaning out my closet this morning
before we were doing it before we're
talking and actually found I have Iron
Giant I didn't even know I had it like
it's in the closet
get on him about getting an Iron Giant
blu-ray out because there isn't a Iron
Giant blu-ray and it needs to be out
yeah tell him to tell them to let go
spider-man that would probably make him
not ever want to come back Oh since we
announced the weakly fooled that ninja I
think we did it yeah we did like we
announced it all now the back issues I
think so yeah I don't remember
yeah the outtakes from anyway okay guys
so so so or biddies gotta run off and do
his thing it sounds gotta run off and do
his thing they've been anything three
hours
yeah oh Rubick Rubick last shout out
last year I gotta plug this little thing
if you're playing Call of Duty advanced
warfare none of my friends are playing
it I'm on PlayStation 4 my name is elder
Buster inviting me hopefully some Call
of Duty someone please be my friends
I'm playing far cry 4 when that comes
down I find my time with call of duty so
sweet by the way we have we'd been and I
did a live play thing on xbox360 like a
few months ago if anyone would like to
see that again let us know it was kind
of fun wait the three of us should do
that like oh you should play like
Borderlands 4 or Borderlands the
pre-sequel whatever it is yeah eat us do
it sounds get real friends he doesn't
know real fries good bye guys yeah I
don't know if sells computer can run it
but if we can actually do that I have
all this setup to stream a video game
and we can have like a four-hour live
live weekly poll I still have that game
that Marvel game Marvel Super girls we
can do that too
yeah I bet yeah I know okay so so far we
love returns for real and for true like
we're gonna bounce off here guys yes